fox news qui a fait son apparition ce
week-end sur les réseaux sociaux une
rumeur selon laquelle cyril hanouna
aurait annoncé quitter l'animation de
tpm paix qui a fait le tour d'internet
ces dernières heures
il s'agit en réalité d'un photomontage
d'un tweet dans lequel baba déclaré
vouloir arrêter de présenter l'émission
face aux inquiétudes de nombreux
internautes cyril à poster démenti ce
matin sur son compte twitter vous avez
vu tout à fond vous êtes vous êtes dit
quoi vous avez non parce que je vais
tout vous dire dans un instant aurait
dit mais ce qui est étonnant c'est est
qu'effectivement ça venait d'un compte
qu'ils étaient certifiés donc ça c'est
dit c'est étonnant et en même temps ça
pouvait être crédible de passe que vous
vous dites à bord tous à vos avril
follower avant de vomir mais avant un
van damme nous avons déjà eu un bon
personne n'a osé mentir dans la wii non
mais moi j'ai pris de panique et de ouf
et je me suis dit je peux pas je le
connais pas assez je suis pas assez en
confiance pour lui dire mais sérieux
c'est vrai série mais je vous dis
vraiment j'ai trop stressé contre m
personne n'a osé maps et pourquoi moi je
me suis répondait pas toujours en ce
moment un quoi en soignant
débrouillez-vous va supporter ce moment
va un peu dans votre grotte
ah oui prenons les messages vous
répondez pas ça me vexe beaucoup mais
vous venez vous cherchez un jour parce
qu'il ne répond pas à toi mon pote c'est
vrai que jean-michel m'envoyant
c'est vrai je suis ma nièce que je peux
je peux ne pas venir
vendredi je dis oui à chypre et juste
avant bien entendu vous avez vu la fecq
nous ce qu'on disait que j'allais
arrêter la présentation de tpm p après
neuf ans d'existence donc de l'émission
alors bien sûr c'est une fête nous mais
néanmoins on travaille déjà sur la
saison prochaine et avec la chaîne on a
décidé qu'on vole annonce très vite
vous savez on l'année prochaine c'est
les 10 ans de tpm paix et sachez qu'on
est en train de travailler
il y aura une dixième année de tp c'est
sûr et certain voilà vous dis donc déjà
ça c'est là la nouvelle à vous annoncer
c'est sûr donc il y aura un tp mp pour
les 10 ans je sais que vous dites tous
est-ce que je vais être là dessus c'est
vous c'est que vous vous dites oui lui
donc mr à la baisse que nous on sera là
ou pas donc
et sachez qu'on a envie de revenir
on sait pas encore si ce sera possible
et je vous dit tout voilà c'est un work
in progress
on a envie de revenir dans le l'ancien
studio tpm pv rien dans les dix ans pour
fêter ça vraiment c'était faire
l'émission quotidienne dont l'ancien
studio on sait pas si c'est encore
possible mais voilà je sais que vous
avez été très nombreux à me demander ça
dans le petit studio donc forcément qui
dit petit studio dit petit salaire pour
les chroniqueurs surtout des petites
équipes et petites équipes et surtout on
pourra aller embêter tout les patrons
comment il se faisait à l'époque donc
voilà on est en train de voir
mais sachez qu'en tout cas là
vraie info c'est qu'il y aura un thé pmp
dixième année j'ai entendu beaucoup de
gens dire que ce serait btp balance
temps presse donc je serai au quotidien
n'a pas de tpm pis ça sera bien des pmp
en access mais vous pourrez avoir des
surprises avec balances ton post le
gréement qui continuera la saison
prochaine mais je vous en dirai plus
plus tard on est très tôt dans la saison
là on dit que dès que le 17 février
on a fêté la saint valentin il ya trois
jours voilà l'année se termine en mars
je ne peux pas travailler comme ça donc
voilà donc rassurés vous et je vous le
dit voilà il aura un pmp 6e année et
j'espère que vous en serez écouter on
sait pour l'instant vous êtes très bien
parti baas et c'est gentil merci merci
merci dans party chez vous
[Applaudissements]